These special episodes of 99% Invisible are brought to you by the Lexus GX and Sirius XM. The new Lexus GX shows how an off-roading overlanding vehicle can also be a true luxury vehicle. Every GX comes standard with Sirius XM, offering a rich array of music, sports, talk, and news. Huge thanks to the Lexus GX and Sirius XM for making this episode possible. Later, we'll meet up with a special guest, SiriusXM host and former UGA Superstar quarterback Aaron Murray and experience the GX first hand.
《99% Invisible》的这些特别节目由雷克萨斯 GX 和 Sirius XM 赞助播出。全新雷克萨斯 GX 展示了越野全地形车如何同时成为真正的豪华座驾。每一款 GX 都标配了 Sirius XM，为您提供丰富的音乐、体育、访谈和新闻节目。非常感谢雷克萨斯 GX 和 Sirius XM 让本期节目的制作成为可能。稍后，我们将采访一位特别嘉宾——SiriusXM 主持人兼前佐治亚大学超级明星四分卫亚伦·默里，并亲自体验雷克萨斯 GX。
So stay tuned. To learn more about the GX, visit Lexus.com slash GX and with every purchase, you'll get three months of SiriusXM free. The all new Lexus GX. Live up to it. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In Athens, Georgia.
所以请继续关注。要了解有关 GX 的更多信息，请访问 Lexus.com/GX，并且每次购买都将获得三个月的免费 Sirius XM 体验。全新雷克萨斯 GX。不负期待。这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯。发自佐治亚州雅典市。
This is the third and final episode in a three-part series of me recording on-location guides to the design features and interesting spots in the cities I love. These bonus episodes are made possible by the new 2024 Lexus GX, who heard this idea and gave the thumbs up and then shipped a Lexus there and shot video of me careening down rural highways. I'm here again with my wife Joy, who has been generous enough to accompany me to these cities so I have someone to tell stories to instead of me talking into a large fuzzy microphone by myself like a weirdo. Hey there. You're not a weirdo. Well yeah you are. So as you know, but other folks may not, I lived in Athens, Georgia for a few years in the mid-90s.
这是三集系列节目的第三集，也是最后一集，记录了我实地探访我所热爱的城市的标志性设计和有趣景点的全过程。这些特别节目由全新 2024 款雷克萨斯 GX 倾情赞助，他们一听到这个创意就表示赞同，随后便把一辆雷克萨斯运到这里，并拍下了我在乡村公路上疾驰的视频。和我在一起的还有我的妻子乔伊，她非常慷慨地陪同我走访这些城市，这样我就能找个人倾诉故事，而不是像个怪人一样独自对着一个巨大的毛绒麦克风说话。大家好。你才不是怪人呢。好吧，你确实是。大家可能都知道，不过其他人或许不知道，我在 90 年代中期曾在佐治亚州雅典市生活过几年。
I moved here to pursue a PhD in plant genetics, but I dropped out and then I just hung out here for a bit, you know, seeing bands, starting a film festival, all things that are very Athens in the 90s things to do. The key part of that story is that I did not graduate from UGA, and mostly that doesn't have a huge effect on my life because today I do things that are totally different than my field of study. But right here at this arch where the town of Athens transitions to the university,
我搬到这里是为了攻读植物遗传学博士学位，但我中途辍学了，然后就在这里闲逛了一阵子，你知道的，看乐队演出、创办电影节，这些都是非常具有 90 年代雅典特色 的活动。这个故事的关键部分在于我并没有从佐治亚大学毕业，而且这基本上对我的生活没有太大影响，因为我今天从事的工作与我的专业领域完全不同。但就在这里，在这个小镇雅典过渡到大学的拱门前，
the fact that I didn't get my degree matters a lot. This pretty modest three-column black metal gateway arch, which serves as the symbol of the university, was erected in 1857 and it stands at the top of a couple of stone stairs that marks the entrance to the campus. Long, long ago it was connected to a fence, but now it just stands alone so people can walk up the stairs and through it, or they can walk up the stairs and through it or they can walk up the stairs and kind of around it But according to tradition I can only walk around it. Can you guess why? Because you didn't graduate from the University of Georgia because I did not graduate from the University of Georgia Now not everyone follows this tradition and on the way here
我没有拿到学位这件事就变得非常重要了。这座外观相当朴素的三柱黑色金属门廊拱门是这所大学的象征，于 1857 年竖立，矗立在几级石阶的顶端，标志着校园的入口。很久很久以前，它曾与一道栅栏相连，但现在它孤零零地立在那里，所以人们可以走上台阶穿过它，或者人们可以走上台阶穿过它，或者人们可以走上台阶然后绕着它走。但根据传统，我只能绕着它走。你猜为什么？因为你没有从佐治亚大学毕业。因为我没有从佐治亚大学毕业。现在，并不是每个人都遵守这个传统，在来这里的路上，
I didn't even know if I was going to like walk around it or through it But I decided that I would walk around it. I'm not sure why. That's the power of tradition. Legend has it that a freshman by the name of Daniel Redfern in 1905 vowed to never cross under the arch because he believed that until he graduated from the university, he did not possess the three virtues for which it stands. that's wisdom, justice, and moderation. And this morphed into this widespread superstition. And it is now believed that passing under the arch before you get your diploma will bring you bad luck or the possibility of never graduating or maybe both.
我甚至不知道自己是会绕着它走还是直接穿过去。但我决定绕着它走。我也不确定为什么。这就是传统的威力。传说在 1905 年，有一个名叫丹尼尔·雷德费恩的大一新生发誓永远不在拱门下穿行，因为他认为，在从大学毕业之前，他不具备拱门所代表的三种美德。即智慧、公正和节制。这演变成了一种广泛的迷信。现在人们普遍认为，在拿到毕业证之前从拱门下穿过会给你带来厄运，或者可能永远无法毕业，也许两者兼而有之。
Are you sure you didn't walk under the arch? I probably did. It's probably all the arch's fault. But you can see here, this is what I love about this, you can see right here a lot of people chose to walk around the arch. Like the right side of the stone step around the arch is totally worn down. It's a little dip of erosion for where all the people are walking around it and not through it. If you think about it, the people crossing here are most likely not graduates. Like when you graduate, you leave soon after. So pretty much the only people who actually pass through here are people who have not yet earned their degree. So it makes sense that many, many people walk around it
你确定你没有从拱门下走过吗？我可能走过。这可能全是拱门的错。但你在这里可以看到，这也是我最喜欢的地方，你可以看到就在这里很多人选择绕过拱门。比如拱门周围石阶的右侧完全被磨损了。由于所有人都在绕着它走而不是穿过去，那里形成了一个因侵蚀而产生的小凹陷。如果你仔细想想，在这里穿行的人极大概率不是毕业生。就像你毕业后不久就会离开一样。所以基本上唯一真正从这里走过的人都是还没有获得学位的人。因此，很多人绕道而行也就顺理成章了，
and that causes that erosion. So like I mentioned before, the gateway arch used to be connected to a fence. So it was like a real gate. Safety wise, it doesn't really matter that this entrance can't be closed now, but it could matter for a different reason and that reason is adverse possession.
而这正是造成这种侵蚀的原因。所以正如我之前提到的，这座入口拱门以前是连着栅栏的。所以它就像是一个真正的门。从安全角度来看，这个入口现在无法关闭其实并不重要，但它可能会因为另一个原因而重要，这个原因就是逆权占有。
Adverse possession is an ancient legal principle that still exists today under which a person who does not have legal title to a piece of land may acquire legal ownership based on continuous possession or occupation of the property without the permission of the legal owner. Basically, if the owner doesn't kick someone off the property, then the squatter can legally become the new owner after a certain amount of time. There are lots of conditions and requirements, but the existence of adverse possession
逆权占有是一个古老的法律原则，至今仍然存在。根据这一原则，对某块土地没有法定所有权的人，如果在未经合法所有人许可的情况下，持续占有或使用该财产，则可以取得法定所有权。基本上，如果所有权人在一段时间后没有将某人赶出该房产，那么占用者就可以在一定期限后合法成为新的所有权人。这其中有很多条件和要求，但逆权占有的存在，
is the reason you see little plaques on sidewalks that grant permission for people to pass over it, even though it is private property, and explicitly states that it will still remain private property of the original owner no matter if people pass over it or not. So gates also function like this, but really only if you can close them and deny someone continuous possession. But the reason why I bring this up at this gate that does not close is because of where you went to grad school. Where did you go to grad school?
就是为什么你在人行道上会看到一些小牌匾，它们允许人们从上面通行（尽管这是私人财产），并明确声明无论人们是否通行，这里仍将是原所有者的私人财产。因此，大门也具有这种功能，但前提是你能把它们关上并剥夺某人持续占有的权利。不过我之所以在这个无法关闭的大门前提起这件事，是因为你读研究生的地方。你在哪里读的研究生？
I went to Columbia. For people who don't know, where is Columbia University? It's in New York City, in the borough of Manhattan. Right. So Columbia is an open campus. The public can cross the grounds if they want to. We toured there with some of the kids on the hottest day of the year. They thought they were going to die. But once a year on a Sunday morning, Columbia locks those gates. And it's not because they're
我在哥伦比亚大学读的。对于不了解的人来说，哥伦比亚大学在哪里？它在纽约市曼哈顿区。没错。所以哥伦比亚大学是一个开放式校园。如果公众愿意，是可以穿过校园的。我们在一年中最热的一天带着一些孩子去那里参观。他们当时觉得快热死了。但一年中的某天，也就是周日的早晨，哥伦比亚大学会把这些大门锁上。这并不是因为他们
doing maintenance or anything. It's just to demonstrate that this land is ours and you, the public, can't make a claim to it. Because the public is kept out once a year for one morning, no one can eventually own it by possession. Now again, I don't think there's any way to close this gate, but I am sure around campus or in whatever town or city you're in, you will find markers guarding against adverse possession, either by legal notification or a physical barrier. Now I am choosing to not walk through the arch, but as a member of the public I think
进行维护或任何操作。这只是为了证明这块土地是我们的，而你们公众不能对它提出所有权主张。因为公众每年被挡在门外一个上午，最终谁也无法通过占有来拥有它。再次声明，我认为没有办法关闭这扇大门，但我确信在校园周围，或者在你所在的任何城镇，你都会发现防范时效取得的标志，无论是通过法律通知还是实体屏障。现在我选择不穿过拱门，但作为公众的一员，我认为
it is important to roam on land that is open to the public. Because adverse possession can work the other way too. Like if the public stops accessing public land, some jerk can fence it off and take it away from us. This is something I always say to the kids, if we don't use rights, we lose rights. Speaking of the inalienable rights of humans and the unconscionably evil act of taking those rights away, let's take a look at the plaque back there beyond the arch. This is the most prominent plaque on campus. It's right here at the entrance and it recounts the founding of the university. It reads in part, endowed with 40,000 acres of land in 1784 and
在向公众开放的土地上漫步是很重要的。因为时效取得反过来也同样适用。比如，如果公众停止使用公共土地，某个混蛋就可以把它圈起来并从我们手中夺走。这是我经常对孩子们说的一句话：如果我们不使用权利，就会失去权利。说到人类不可剥夺的权利以及剥夺这些权利的令人发指的邪恶行为，让我们来看看拱门后面的那块牌匾。这是校园里最显眼的牌匾。它就在入口处，上面讲述了这所大学的建校历史。部分内容写道，1784年被赋予40000英亩土地，并
chartered in 1785. The charter was the first granted by a state for a government-controlled university. After Louisville and then Greensboro were first selected, the current site was chosen. The first president and author of the school's charter, Abraham Baldwin, resigned when the doors opened and was succeeded by—yadda yadda yada yada more names. Okay, here is the key part. Quote, during the war for southern independence most of the students entered the Confederate Army. The university closed its doors in 1864 and did not open again until January 1866. After the war many of the Confederate veterans became students. It goes on naming famous professors and chancellors from there.
于1785年获得特许状。该特许状是州政府为一所政府控制的大学颁发的第一个特许状。在最初选中路易斯维尔和格林斯伯勒之后，最终选定了当前的位置。第一任校长兼学校特许状的起草人亚伯拉罕·鲍德温在学校开门时辞职，接替他的是——巴拉巴拉，还有更多的名字。好了，关键部分来了。引文：“在南方独立战争期间，大部分学生加入了邦联军队。大学于1864年关闭，直到1866年1月才重新开学。战后，许多邦联退伍军人成为了学生。”接下来还列举了当时著名的教授和校长。
In the bottom corner, you see that it was erected in 1991. So you were born and raised in California. Have you ever heard the phrase, the war for Southern independence? No, I haven't. The quote unquote war for Southern independence is pathetic white supremacy language steeped in racist, revisionist, lost cause ideology. There is no excuse for it. A few years ago, the Athens Cultural Affairs Commission recommended that additional text
在右下角，你可以看到它是1991年竖立的。所以你是在加利福尼亚出生长大的。你听说过“南方独立战争”这个词吗？没有，我没听说过。所谓的“南方独立战争”是可悲的白人至上主义语言，浸透了种族主义、修正主义的失落因意识形态。这没有任何借口。几年前，雅典文化事务委员会建议在这个标志上
be added to this marker and they had a bunch of other recommendations for public art that told the full history of slavery and white supremacy here. So more people can be welcome in this space. But I'm not sure what has been done. This plaque is still here, however, and it is bad. And, you know, I'm all about always read the plaque. But when this thing isn't being outright racist, it's just a boring list of names.
添加额外的文字，他们对公共艺术还有一堆其他的建议，讲述这里奴隶制和白人至上主义的完整历史。这样可以让更多的人在这个空间里受到欢迎。但我不知道目前做了什么。不过这块牌匾依然在这里，而且它很糟糕。而且，你知道的，我一向主张“仔细阅读牌匾”。但当这东西不那么赤裸裸地表现出种族主义时，它就只是一份无聊的名字名单。
Like an extremely dull Klansman wrote it. Literally anything would be better. And I say this because this is a beautiful place. I loved going to school here. I loved living here. Everyone here deserves better. So walking around that arch, that's a tradition that I can get behind.
就像一个极其沉闷的3K党成员写的。 literalmente任何东西都比这强。我这么说是因为这是一个美丽的地方。我喜欢在这里上学，喜欢在这里生活。这里的每个人都值得拥有更好的。所以绕过那个拱门，这是一个我可以支持的传统。
Molly coddling the people who want to keep lost cause rhetoric alive, that is a southern tradition that absolutely needs to go. Especially because, you know, a university and a university town are all about learning and growth.
娇惯那些想要维持“失落因”论调活着的人，绝对是一种需要摒弃的南方传统。特别是考虑到，你知道的，大学和大学镇的核心就是学习和成长。
There is so much potential for excellent, smart, interesting, historically accurate, nuanced, challenging, comforting, inclusive messages that could be embedded all over the landscape here. This is a place that has done great things and they should be highlighted. I think this place is worth it and I think it's worth the hard work to make it better. So always read the plaque, but you know, with copyhats. Okay, so we're gonna walk a few blocks that way to another historical marker, which tells a great story.
这里有如此巨大的潜力，可以融入各种精彩、聪明、有趣、历史准确、细致入微、充满挑战、令人宽慰且包容的信息，这些信息本可以嵌入这里的整个景观中。这是一个做过伟大事情的地方，应该得到重点突出。我认为这个地方很值得，而且为了让它变得更好，付出艰苦的努力是值得的。所以一定要阅读牌匾，但你知道，要带着批判的眼光。好了，我们要往那个方向走几个街区到一个历史地标，那里有一个很棒的故事。
Up a cobblestone street and kind of protruding out into the intersection of Finley and Deering is the tree that owns itself. It is a white oak that, according to legend, has legal ownership of itself and the eight feet around it. The story is that a man named William Jackson, who was maybe a professor at the university, maybe a doctor, maybe a colonel, maybe all three of those things had lovely childhood memories of this tree and desiring to protect it for all time deeded the tree the ownership of itself and its surrounding land.
沿着卵石街道往上走，有点突入芬利街和迪林街的交汇处，那就是“属于它自己的树”。这是一棵白橡树，根据传说，它在法律上拥有它自己以及周围八英尺土地的所有权。故事是这样的：一个名叫威廉·杰克逊的人，他可能是大学教授，可能是医生，可能是上校，也可能兼具这三种身份，他对这棵树有着美好的童年记忆，为了永远保护它，他将这棵树及周围土地的所有权契赠给了这棵树本身。
This happened sometime in the 1820s. There is no real legal basis for this tree owning itself. But for nearly 200 years, the stated position of the Athens-Clarke County Unified Government is that this tree, in spite of the law, does indeed own itself. It is the policy of the city of Athens to maintain it as a public street tree. It has gone through some rough times. It needed some help in 1906 and George Foster Peabody of the namesake of the Peabody Awards which are given out by UGA paid to have new soil and these little concrete bollards and chain barricade around it. He also paid
这发生在19世纪20年代的某个时候。这棵树拥有自己并没有真正的法律依据。但在近200年的时间里，雅典-克拉克县统一政府的公开立场是，尽管有法律规定，但这棵树确实属于它自己。雅典市的政策是将其作为一所公共街道树木进行维护。它经历了一些艰难时期。它在1906年需要一些帮助，皮博迪奖（由佐治亚大学颁发）的同名赞助者乔治·福斯特·皮博迪出资为其铺设了新土壤，并安装了这些小混凝土路障和铁链护栏。他还出资
for the plaque. The old one is around the corner is very worn, but the new one has a more legible inscription, and it reads, For and in consideration of the great love I bear this tree, and the great desire I have for its protection for all time, I convey entire possession of itself, and all land within eight feet of the tree on all sides. William H. Jackson. This is also a brass plaque that reveals that this is not actually the original tree. That tree fell down in 1946 and it was
制作了牌匾。旧牌匾在拐角处，已经非常破旧了，但新牌匾上的铭文更清晰，上面写着：“出于我对这棵树怀有的巨大爱意，以及为了永远保护它的巨大愿望，我把树本身的所有权，以及树四周八英尺内所有土地的全部所有权转让给它。威廉·H·杰克逊。”这也是一块黄铜牌匾，它透露出这其实并不是原来的那棵树。那棵树在1946年倒塌了，并被
replaced so some people call this the son of the tree that owns itself. I love the spirit of this. This is a tradition with no real-world grounding at all. Like there is no way that this tree actually legally owns itself, but people treat it as real because this story and this idea represents the best of our values and everyone can see it and they can see it etched into stone.
替换了，所以有些人称这棵树为“属于它自己的树的儿子”。我喜欢这种精神。这是一个完全没有现实依据的传统。比如这棵树在法律上绝不可能真正属于它自己，但人们把它当作真的，因为这个故事和这个想法代表了我们价值观中最美好的部分，每个人都能看到它，而且能看到它被镌刻在石头上。
So let's head to a park I'm excited to check out because it was not here when I lived here and it sounds so cool. So we just got biscuits and sausage gravy from mama's boy and walked to the river behind it and to this amazing park. This is a lovely example of the rails to trails movement that gained traction in the early 2000s as people saw more and more opportunities to convert disused railway routes into urban trail systems. In New York City, a series of old elevated rail lines on the west side were slated for
所以让我们前往一个我很兴奋去探索的公园，因为自我在这里生活时它并不在这里，而且听起来太酷了。我们刚从“妈妈男孩”买了饼干和香肠肉汁，然后走到它后面的河流以及这个令人惊叹的公园。这是2000年代初兴起的“铁路改步道”运动的一个可爱例子，当时人们看到越来越多的机会将废弃的铁路线改造成城市步道系统。在纽约市，西侧的一系列旧高架铁路线一度面临
demolition until citizens got really serious about saving it. And ultimately those raised routes became the now super popular Highline Park trails, which took the kids there too. Yeah, it was beautiful. Also in the early 2000s, an old elevated rail line trussle was going to be turned down right here where this park is, but it was saved because of the trussle's cultural significance. And that cultural significance is that in the spring of 1983, one of the greatest bands to ever exist, R.E.M. released its debut album, Murmur, and the track list on its reverse side was overlaid on a photo of an old local wood railway trestle
拆除，直到市民们开始非常认真地努力拯救它。最终，这些高架路线变成了如今超级受欢迎的高速铁路公园步道，这也把孩子们带到了那里。是的，它很美。同样在2000年代初，就在这个公园所在的地方，一条旧的高架铁路线高架桥本来要被拆除，但由于这座高架桥的文化意义，它被保留了下来。而这种文化意义在于，在1983年春天，有史以来最伟大的乐队之一R.E.M.发行了他们的首张专辑《Murmur》，其背面曲目列表叠加在一张当地旧木质铁路高架桥的照片上，
that stood right here. Over the decades, the bridge has been this destination for fans of the band. When I lived here, people climbed on the trestle, they nearly killed themselves, and the locals were committed to it being preserved in some way. Coincidentally, the same year Murmur debuted in 1983, something else happened that led to this park being here and to the Trussell's preservation. Congress amended the National Trail System Act, and in doing so, they made rails-to-trails conversions easier to implement. So there was cultural significance thanks to REM. Thanks to the National Trail System Act, there was a pathway to turn this into a park trail.
而这座高架桥就矗立在这里。几十年代以来，这座桥一直是该乐队粉丝的目的地。我住在这里时，人们爬上高架桥，差点把自己摔死，而当地人则致力于以某种方式将其保存下来。巧合的是，在《Murmur》于1983年首次亮相的同一年，发生了一件另外的事情，促成了这个公园的存在以及高架桥的保存。国会修改了《国家步道系统法》，通过这样做，他们使铁路改步道项目的实施变得更容易。因此，由于REM，这里有了文化意义。由于《国家步道系统法》，这里有了将其变成公园步道的途径。
But there was still the issue of what to do with the old wooden trestle itself that went over the river. So park planners wanted to use the bridge as part of the trail. But the old abandoned structure that's depicted on the album was deemed too unsafe. So there was a thought to keep know, to keep it as is and the trail would just go alongside it using a series of switchbacks to just bypass the
但仍然存在如何处理横跨河流的旧木制高架桥本身的问题。因此，公园规划者希望将这座桥用作步道的一部分。但专辑中所描绘的那个被废弃的旧结构被认为太不安全了。因此，曾有人考虑将其保持原样，步道则从旁边绕过，通过一系列的折返路线完全绕过
bridge entirely. But the solution, you know, was seen as, you know, defeating the great goal of creating a continuous safe flat trail open to people of all ages that crosses over the river. So there was talk of replacing the old structure plank by plank, like a ship of Theseus type of thing, but that was deemed a little too unrealistic. Ultimately, it became clear that the original framework had to come down and be replaced by something new. Most of the structural elements had been just rotted beyond repair.
这座桥。但是，你知道的，这个解决方案被认为违背了创造一条适合所有年龄段、跨越河流的连续、安全、平坦步道的伟大目标。因此，曾有人讨论过像“忒修斯之船”那样，一块木板一块木板地替换旧结构，但这被认为有点太不切实际了。最终，人们清楚地认识到，最初的框架必须拆除，并换成新东西。大部分结构部件都已经腐烂得无法修复。
In its place is what you see in front of you. This replacement bridge mimics the overall aesthetic of the wood-framed murmur bridge, but also features new robust engineering elements like a set of arch steel supports. Another nice new addition are the overlook platforms up there that are midway across Trail Creek. They're really lovely. Construction of this new pedestrian trail was finished about a year ago, and it carries forward a lot of the look and vibe
取而代之的是你眼前的景象。这座替代桥模仿了木质框架的《Murmur》桥的整体美学，同时也采用了新的坚固工程元素，比如一组拱形钢支撑。另一个很好的新添置是Trail Creek中段上方的观景平台。它们真的很可爱。这条新行人步道的大约在一年前完工，它延续了许多复古
of the vintage Murmur Bridge. It is a really worthy tribute to the past, but it's infused with new life and new function. It's this perfect mix of nostalgia and real progress, like making this community better and more welcoming for all citizens. At the official opening of the Firefly Bridge in April of 2023, REM's murmur played in the background, which is a really nice accompaniment to any civic ceremony. Projects like this can be this huge boon to the public. Railway pathways, especially, these are really rare direct routes to and through the hearts
《Murmur》桥的外观和氛围。它是对过去的一个非常值得的致敬，但又注入了新的活力和新的功能。它是怀旧与真正进步的完美结合，就像让这个社区变得更好、对所有市民更具包容性一样。在2023年4月萤火虫大桥的官方开幕式上，背景音乐播放了REM的《Murmur》，这对于任何市民庆典来说都是一个非常好的伴奏。像这样的项目可以给公众带来巨大的福音。铁路步道，尤其是这些通往并穿过城市核心的稀有直接路线，
of cities. These paths cut across city grids in ways that would be effectively impossible to carve out from the filled-in fabric of modern urban environments. So they're really special and worth the effort of converting them for modern use. This Firefly Trail, which, you know, this is a small part of this 39-mile proposed path, joins like a host of really impressive rails-to-trails projects across the U.S., including the 606 Trail in Chicago and the Midtown Greenway in Minneapolis. These have already been extensively built out,
这些路径以现代城市环境中从填满的肌理中雕刻出来几乎不可能的方式穿过城市网格。所以它们非常特别，值得花精力将其转换为现代用途。这条萤火虫步道（你知道的，这只是这条拟议中的39英里长路径的一小部分）与美国各地众多令人印象深刻的“铁路改步道”项目联合在一起，包括芝加哥的606步道和明尼阿波利斯的米德敦绿道。这些都已经得到了大规模建设，
as well as the Los Angeles River Greenway and other urban projects that are still in the works. Kurt and I talk about this a lot in our book, The 99% Invisible City, which I'm sure you've read cover to cover many times. I did. Of course I did. And I listen to it.
还有仍在建设中的洛杉矶河绿道以及其他城市项目。库尔特和我在我们的书《99%隐形城市》中经常谈到这一点，我相信你一定从头到尾读过很多遍。我读过。我当然读过。而且我也听过。
I think it's safe to say that the aesthetics of the Firefly Bridge would be totally different if it weren't for REM making the Trestle famous. And I think that's safe to say that the aesthetics of the Firefly Bridge would be totally different if it weren't for REM making the Trussell famous. And I think that's glorious. It's really, really nice. So we're going to stick with the album Murmur because it's one of the greatest albums of all time. So if you flip over the LP to the front, you will see a picture of an outdoor landscape
我认为可以肯定地说，如果没有REM让这座高架桥成名，萤火虫大桥的美学将完全不同。而且我认为可以肯定地说，如果没有REM让这座高架桥成名，萤火虫大桥的美学将完全不同。我认为这太棒了。真的非常非常棒。所以我们将继续关注《Murmur》这张专辑，因为它是史上最伟大的专辑之一。因此，如果你把黑胶唱片翻到正面，你会看到一幅户外风景的照片，
covered in a vine called Kudzu. Have you ever heard of kudzu? I haven't, but it sounds, that's a cool word. Yeah, kudzu is an ornamental vine from Japan. It's everywhere in the south, and that was by design. In the 1930s, when the Dust Bowl was raging, the U.S. government was rightfully deeply concerned about soil erosion. So they cultivated kudzu seedlings and paid people to plant it. So they paid both the landowners to plant it on their land and teams of young men to do the job, including my grandfather who grew up in Atlanta. That was his one of his summer jobs. So kudzu was planted everywhere and in the right conditions. It is a very, very
上面覆盖着一种叫做葛藤（Kudzu）的藤蔓。你听说过葛藤吗？我没听说过，但听起来，这是个很酷的词。是的，葛藤是一种来自日本的观赏性藤蔓。它在南方随处可见，这是刻意为之的。在20世纪30年代风沙暴肆虐时，美国政府理所当然地对水土流失深感担忧。因此，他们培育了葛藤幼苗并花钱让人种植。因此，他们既花钱让土地所有者在自己的土地上种植，又花钱雇佣年轻男子团队来完成这项工作，其中包括在亚特兰大长大的我的祖父。那是他夏天的其中一份工作。因此，葛藤被种植在各地，在合适的条件下。它是一个非常非常
aggressive invader. On the cover of the murmur album you can see what it does it just overwhelms everything in its path. It grows over abandoned structures like cars and abandoned buildings, it climbs trees and signs. I remember it being called the vine that ate the south. I lived in fear of it growing up. It was like quicksand. You know you remember being afraid of quicksand? I thought it was possible that kudzu would consume the entire United States. It turns out it's maybe not as bad as all that. And I only read this recently in an article in the Smithsonian from 2015. Kudzu needs a lot of sun. It can be kept in check by grazing.
具有侵略性的入侵者。在《Murmur》专辑的封面，你可以看到它是如何做到的，它只是压倒了它路径上的一切。它在废弃的结构（如汽车和废弃建筑）上生长，它爬上树木和标志。我记得它被称为“吃掉南方的藤蔓”。我从小就生活在对它的恐惧中。它就像流沙一样。你知道你还记得害怕流沙吗？我曾以为葛藤可能会吞噬整个美国。事实证明，它可能并没有那么糟糕。我最近才在《史密森尼》杂志2015年的一篇文章中读到这一点。葛藤需要大量的阳光。通过放牧可以控制它。
Also one of the beetles that eats it in Japan finally made its way over and it's also eating it here. But still, all along roadsides and in abandoned places, it really thrives. So it's at its worst where humans can see it. But forests are not as overrun as you could imagine while you're seeing it speeding down rural highways. It's still a big symbol of the South. I was on the founding committee of the first Athens Film Festival in the 1990s,
另外，在日本吃它的一种甲虫终于漂洋过海来到了这里，现在它也在这里吃它。尽管如此，在路边和废弃的地方，它确实生长得很繁茂。所以它最糟糕的一面是人类能看到的地方。但森林并没有像你在以极高速度驶过乡村公路时想象的那样被过度侵占。它仍然是南方的一个巨大象征。我在20世纪90年代是第一届雅典电影节的发起委员会成员，
and the Kudzu was the name of the award for the best film. It's all over Southern Gothic stories. It's a very creepy, creeping vine, but I was happy to learn it's not quite as bad as I was raised to believe. But it's better than the doomsday scenario that plagued my brain as a kid. ["The Last Supper"]
而“葛藤”就是最佳电影奖的名字。它充斥在南方哥特式故事中。它是一种非常诡异、蔓延的藤蔓，但我很高兴得知它并没有我从小被灌输的那样糟糕。但它比困扰我童年大脑的末日场景要好得多。["最后的晚餐"]
So the last story I want to tell you is a very 99PI thing that happened to us when we were driving to the Luxus photo shoot, and I'll tell you that story after this. This special episode of 99% Invisible is brought to you by the 2024 Lexus GX and Sirius XM. The Lexus GX is at the apex of high-end luxury and high-end utility, which means you can get very comfortable with massaging seats and a drink cooler in the center console And you can tow four tons of whatever makes you happy behind you that the towing capacity of
所以我想给你们讲的最后一个故事是一个非常99PI风格的故事，发生在我们在开车去雷克萨斯拍照的路上，我将在之后给你们讲这个故事。这个特别篇的《99%隐形》由2024款雷克萨斯GX和Sirius XM为您倾情呈现。雷克萨斯GX处于高端豪华和高端实用性的巅峰，这意味着你可以通过按摩座椅和中控台里的饮料冷却器感到非常舒适，并且你可以在身后拖拽四吨任何让你高兴的东西，它的拖拽能力达到了
8,000 pounds that's that's a lot. That's a lot That's Eric Kavanaugh senior advertising planner and our guide to the Lexus GX to be able to confidently tow any a utility Trailer of that weight is really impressive. The V6 engine being the twin turbo, the feel when you really step on the gas, you have that instantaneous acceleration from the turbos. I'm just so excited for, I wanna drive this one more often.
8000磅，那真的是很多。那是埃里克·卡瓦纳（Eric Kavanaugh），高级广告策划员兼我们的雷克萨斯GX向导。能够自信地拖拽任何那个重量的实用拖车真的很让人印象深刻。V6发动机是双涡轮增压的，当你真正踩下油门时的那种感觉，涡轮带来的瞬间加速感。我太兴奋了，我想更经常地驾驶这款车。
I don't know how much things weigh, like how much is 8,000 pounds what should I be thinking of? We're gonna have to save that car station for any day. It gets into gross combined vehicle trailer weight rating tongue weight etc but I would think of you know a medium-sized boat would fit right in line there and for anyone that is towing should know that they should read their owner's manual and understand how much their trailer weighs and what the combined weight is of the trailer and their vehicle so
我不知道东西有多重，比如8000磅到底是多少，我应该怎么去联想？我们得把那场汽车讲座留到哪天再说。它涉及到总组合车辆拖车重量额定值、舌重等，但我想你会发现，一艘中型船正好符合这个标准，对于任何拖车的人来说，他们应该知道自己应该阅读车主手册，了解他们的拖车有多重，以及拖车和车辆的组合重量是多少，所以
But tons of information on Lexus.com GX if you want to inquire more about the different towing capacities by grade and all those differences between the different models. Cool. Thank you. We checked with Lexus and they said the towing capacity was over 9,000 pounds on some models. So like our friend Eric said, check your owner's manual. With the all new Lexus GX, you can get the whole
但是Lexus.com GX上有大量的信息，如果你想更多地了解不同级别的不同牵引能力以及不同型号之间的所有这些差异。酷。谢谢。我们向雷克萨斯核实过，他们说某些型号的牵引能力超过了9000磅。所以就像我们的朋友埃里克说的，查阅你的车主手册。有了全新的雷克萨斯GX，你可以获得整个
crew together, be very comfortable, get out there and take on the world. Now I love music and I love news and I love talk radio, but to me there's something really special about sports on the radio. And when you're in the Deep South, that means you're listening to and you're talking about SEC college football. And it just so happens that SiriusXM has a channel for that and the perfect person to be your guide to the SEC. Aaron Murray, I currently work as a host for SiriusXM, the SEC channel, ESPN as a commentator for collegiate football, and then president of the players' lounge.
大家聚在一起，感到非常舒适，走出去迎接整个世界。现在，我热爱音乐，热爱新闻，也热爱谈话类广播，但对我来说，广播里的体育节目有一种非常特殊的东西。当你在美国南部时，这意味着你在收听并谈论东南联盟（SEC）的大学橄榄球碰巧的是，SiriusXM有一个专门的频道播放这个，而成为你了解SEC的最佳向导的人是亚伦·穆雷。我目前担任SiriusXM的主持人、SEC频道的主持人、ESPN的大学橄榄球评论员，然后还是球员休息室（The Players' Lounge）的总裁。
So just a few things that take up my time and a father of two as well. Tell me about your career at UGA. I got here in 2009 and redshirt my first year so I didn't play my first year. Played the next four years, 2010 to 2013 and was pretty successful. Set numerous SEC records for the Southeastern Conference
所以这些事情占用了我的一些时间，同时我也是两个孩子的父亲。跟我聊聊你在佐治亚大学（UGA）的职业生涯吧。我是在2009年来到这里的，第一年红衫（保留资格），所以第一年没有上场。接下来的四年里我都有上场，从2010年到2013年，取得了相当不错的成绩。我为东南联盟创造了多项SEC纪录
which still stand today, touchdowns, yards, someone just broke my completion percentage record, but the other two stand, which are the ones I really want, especially the touchdown. So it was a really good career. I had a great time, played in some really big games, played in a couple of SEC Championship games that we were close to, unfortunately, winning. One came down to the final play of the game, sadly, but it was a lot of fun, a lot of great memories and like I said, a lot of great memories.
这些纪录至今依然保持着，包括达阵次数、传球码数——虽然传球成功率的纪录刚刚被人打破了，但另外两项依然保留着，这也是我最想要的，尤其是达阵纪录。所以这是一段非常美好的职业生涯。我度过了一段伟大的时光，参加了一些非常棒的比赛，还参加了几场我们差点就能赢下的SEC冠军赛。遗憾的是，其中一场比赛战到了比赛的最后一刻，但那依然非常有趣，有很多美好的回忆，就像我说的，有很多美好的回忆。
And like I said, a lot of great success, which allowed me to then live out my dream of getting a few years in the NFL. For people who don't know, okay, so there's college football, and then there's SEC college football. Tell me about the distinction there. It's different.
就像我说的，我取得了巨大的成功，这也让我能够实现梦想，在NFL度过了几年。对于那些不太了解的人来说，好吧，这里有大学橄榄球，然后还有SEC大学橄榄球。能跟我讲讲这两者的区别吗？它们是不一样的。
I always saw people in the state of Georgia when it comes to like the hierarchy of just teams in general. Obviously you have the Falcons, you have the Braves, you have the Hawks, you got Georgia football are kind of like the big four. If you had a rank them, it's Georgia football one, a significant drop, probably the Braves, Falcons, maybe even like United, like United's awesome.
我经常看到佐治亚州的人们在讨论各种球队的层级结构时。显然，你有猎鹰队（Falcons）、勇士队（Braves）、老鹰队（Hawks），而佐治亚大学橄榄球就像是四大豪门之一。如果你给它们排个名，佐治亚大学橄榄球排在第一位，然后大幅下降，大概才是勇士队、猎鹰队，甚至可能是联队（United）——联队真的很棒。
Like soccer has gotten really popular in Georgia, especially in Atlanta. But like there's a big drop from Georgia football, which is not a professional sport to everything else. And that's just the South. I mean, you have Alabama where there's no professional teams. So people love and don't even talk to their family members when it's Auburn, Alabama week, for goodness sakes.
就像足球在佐治亚州变得非常受欢迎一样，特别是在亚特兰大。但是从作为非职业体育运动的佐治亚大学橄榄球，到其他所有体育运动，中间有着巨大的断层。这就是南方。我的意思是，在阿拉巴马州，那里甚至没有职业球队。所以当奥本大学对阵阿拉巴马大学的那周到来时，人们甚至会深爱并拒绝和自己的家庭成员说话，天哪。
It's different. And that was one of the things that were eyeopening to me because I thought like, okay, I'm just gonna go play football. I didn't realize that my performance on a given Saturday affected so many people the way it did. I mean, there was a time where like, we had one loss my junior season to South Carolina. I got home and my house on campus was egged and tepied.
这感觉完全不同。这也是让我大开眼界的事件之一，因为我想着，好吧，我只是去打橄榄球。我没有意识到我在某个周六的表现竟然会以这种方式影响到这么多人。我的意思是，有一次，在我大三赛季，我们对阵南卡罗来纳州输了一场比赛。我回到家，发现我在校园里的房子被砸了鸡蛋，还被卷纸（TP）恶作剧了。
I was getting hate mail and hate messages like on social media and the message boards and all that and like I just thought I was coming to play football. I didn't realize like it's it's I'm like I don't want to use the word religion but it's pretty darn close to to that here in the south especially college football and at times it's great because you're worshiped and you're loved and you get free drinks and food and pats on the back but then when things aren't going well, like you don't even want to walk around campus,
我收到了很多仇恨邮件和社交媒体以及留言板上的恶毒私信，诸如此类。我本以为我只是来打橄榄球的。我没有意识到，这……我不想用“宗教”这个词，但在南方，这真的非常接近这种感觉，尤其是大学橄榄球。有时候这种感觉棒极了，因为你受到崇拜和喜爱，能免费喝到饮料、吃到食物，还能被人拍肩膀鼓励；但当事情进展不顺利时，比如你甚至都不想在校园里走动，
especially the quarterback position, because you are praised for wins and you are blamed most of the time for the losses. So now you do commentary for the SEC channel on SiriusXM. Tell me about what the channel is and tell me about what your job is there. The SEC has been the most dominant conference in college football for two decades now.
尤其是四分卫这个位置，因为你因胜利而受到赞美，而大多数时候你则要为失败承担责任。所以现在你为SiriusXM的SEC频道做评论。能跟我聊聊这个频道是什么，以及你在那里具体负责什么工作吗？二十年来，SEC一直是大学橄榄球界最具统治力的联盟。
They've had the most championships, they've had the most first-rounders, they've had the most Heismans, everything, all the awards. So it's the best conference in America and we have to focus solely on that for me for three hours a day, which is pretty easy, pretty fun. And I think it's going to be only more and more obviously as this conference continues to grow. So how did you go from being a player to being a commentator? And I think it's gonna be only more and more, obviously as this conference continues to grow. So how did you go from being a player to being a commentator?
他们拥有最多的总冠军，拥有最多的首轮秀，拥有最多的海斯曼奖（Heismans）得主，一切大奖都被他们包揽。所以这是全美最好的联盟，对我来说，我们每天只需要专注于此三个小时，这相当轻松，也相当有趣。而且随着这个联盟继续发展，显而易见，这种影响力只会越来越大。那么，你是如何从一名球员转变成一名评论员的呢？而且，随着这个联盟继续发展，显而易见，这种影响力只会越来越大。那么，你是如何从一名球员转变成一名评论员的呢？
I never thought I'd get into media when I was done, but it kind of just fell into my lap my first year at the NFL to jump into commentary. And I kept being told like, hey, if you're gonna do games or do studio work, the best way to improve is to do radio because radio is more difficult. You don't have a game to help you.
当我退役时，我从没想过自己会涉足媒体行业，但在我进入NFL的第一年，这个机会就这么自然而然地降临到了我头上，让我开始尝试做评论。人们不断地告诉我：“嘿，如果你想解说比赛或做演播室工作，提高的最佳途径就是做广播，因为广播更有难度。你没有比赛画面来帮你。”
You don't have graphics to help you. Like you have to fill air for two, three hours. I think there is a level of credibility when I jump on a broadcast or jump on my serious show and my commentator is like, oh, we're here in Athens, Georgia for Georgia versus so-and-so. And I'm here with the SEC's all-time leading quarterback in touchdowns.
你没有图表来帮你。你必须填补两到三个小时的空白时间。我认为，当我参与一场赛事转播或主持我的Sirius频道节目时，如果我的搭档说：“哦，我们今天来到了佐治亚州雅典市，观看佐治亚对阵某某队的比赛，而我身边这位是SEC历史上传球达阵次数最多的传奇四分卫”，这本身就带有一种可信度。
It does add a level of credibility for when people listen to a game or show. Are you live on the air or do you record a little ahead of time? Oh, we're live. So I just plug on in and sit at my desk and pray my dogs don't bark too much or my son gets home from school like at 530 and he loves to just run into my office, Dad, Dad, Dad. I'm like, I'm on radio. Shh, be quiet. He'll jump on the headset sometimes and say hello, good dogs, and then he'll go off to his little play area downstairs and have some fun.
这确实为人们收听比赛或节目时增添了一种可信度。你们是在节目中进行直播，还是会提前录制一点？哦，我们是直播。所以我只需要插上设备，坐在办公桌前，祈祷我的狗不要叫得太厉害，或者祈祷我儿子五点半左右放学回家——他最喜欢突然冲进我的办公室大喊：“爸爸，爸爸，爸爸！”我会对他说：“我在做广播呢，嘘，安静点。”有时他还会戴上耳机打个招呼，说“狗狗好”，然后就会去楼下的儿童游戏区玩得开心。
You can hear Aaron Murray on the SEC channel, which is just one of a bunch of riveting sports radio channels included with your free three-month subscription to SiriusXM with the purchase of a new Lexus GX. To learn more about the GX, visit Lexus.com slash GX. The all-new Lexus GX. Live up to it. So on our way to the Lexus photoshoot, a very 99PI thing happened. North Georgia was built around trains. The original name of Atlanta was Terminus, because it was at the end of both the Atlantic and Western rail lines. As such, someone proposed the name Atlantica Pacifica to replace the name Terminus, I presume
你可以在SEC频道收听亚伦·穆雷的节目，该频道是购买全新雷克萨斯GX时附赠的SiriusXM免费三个月订阅中包含的一系列引人入胜的体育广播频道之一。要了解有关GX的更多信息，请访问Lexus.com slash GX。全新雷克萨斯GX。活出可能。因此，在我们前往雷克萨斯拍照地点的路上，发生了一件非常具有“99%隐形”风格的事。佐治亚州北部是围绕着铁路建立起来的。亚特兰大的最初名字叫“终点站”（Terminus），因为它位于大西洋和西部铁路线的终点。因此，有人提议用“亚特兰大太平洋”（Atlantica Pacifica）来取代“终点站”这个名字，我猜
because it sounded prettier, and that was quickly shortened to Atlanta. I live next to the train line in Normal Town, and we passed my old neighborhood on the way to do the interview with Aaron and take pictures of the Lexus GX. But we were stopped along the way because a tall truck tried to get under a low train overpass and the top of it got sheared off, which reminded me of one of my favorite stories from the 99% of Visible City about the Canopner Bridge. Nicknamed the Canopner Bridge, there is a rail overpass in Durham, North Carolina,
是因为听起来更优美，这个名字很快就被简称为亚特兰大。我住在诺曼镇（Normal Town）的铁路线旁，在去对亚伦进行采访并拍摄雷克萨斯GX的路上，我们路过了我以前的街区。但在途中我们被拦了下来，因为有一辆高大的卡车试图从一个低矮的铁路立交桥下穿过，结果车顶被削掉了，这让我想起了《99%隐形城市》中我最喜欢的故事之一——坎普纳桥（Canopner Bridge）。这座被称为坎普纳桥的铁路立交桥位于北卡罗来纳州达勒姆市，
that has become famous for scraping the tops off of trucks that dare pass beneath its tracks. The Norfolk Southern Gregson Street Overpass was designed to allow safe passage for vehicles up to around 12 feet tall, which probably seemed like more than enough overhead when it was constructed in 1940. Over the years, though, trucks got taller, and more and more trucks hit the bridge. Despite the implementation of a series of bright signs, flashing lights, and other warnings that the driver's too tall vehicle is about to be loudly decapitated, these collisions just kept happening. A local resident named Juergen Henn
它因专门刮擦那些胆敢从其轨道下方通过的卡车车顶而闻名。诺福克南方铁路公司的格雷格森街立交桥（Norfolk Southern Gregson Street Overpass）的设计初衷是允许高达12英尺左右的车辆安全通过，在1940年建造时，这可能显得绰绰有余。然而多年过去，卡车变得越来越高，撞桥的卡车也越来越多。尽管采取了一系列亮眼的标示、闪烁的灯光以及其他警告措施，提醒司机车辆过高即将面临被大声“斩首”的危险，但这类碰撞事故仍然不断发生。当地一位名叫于尔根·亨恩（Juergen Henn）的居民
was working in a nearby building when he began to notice the high frequency of incidents involving the bridge. It's pretty crazy sometimes. I'll sit there at my desk working peacefully and all of a sudden there's this massive crash out there and I almost fall out of my chair. In 2008, he installed a video camera to document the collisions. Since then, he has captured and posted over 100 videos. These short films capture a delightful spectrum of mayhem, at least for those inclined towards
当时在附近的一栋大楼里工作，他开始注意到涉及该桥的事故发生频率极高。有时候这真的是太疯狂了。我有时会平静地坐在办公桌前工作，突然外面就会传来一声巨大的撞击巨响，我差点从椅子上摔下来。2008年，他安装了一台摄像机来记录这些碰撞事故。从那时起，他已经拍摄并发布了100多段视频。这些短片捕捉到了一系列令人愉悦的混乱场面，至少对于那些喜欢这种场面的人来说是这样的。
infrastructural schadenfreude. Especially tall trucks are stopped entirely by the bridge and bounce back like a person hitting their head on a kitchen cabinet. Shorter vehicles slide under with just a painful screeching sound. And in some cases where the vehicle's height is just right, or rather just wrong, the entire tops of the vehicles are peeled back like a sardine can, hence the name, the can opener bridge. After watching dozens and dozens of these incidents, one starts to wonder how such an obvious problem can go unfixed for so long.
基础设施的幸灾乐祸。尤其是高大的卡车会被桥梁完全拦住，像人撞到厨房橱柜上一样弹回来。较低的车辆则伴随着痛苦的刺耳摩擦声滑过去。在某些情况下，车辆的高度刚好合适，或者说刚好不合适，整个车顶就像沙丁鱼罐头一样被剥开，这也是“开罐器桥”这个名字的由来。在观看了几十起这样的事故后，人们不禁开始好奇，如此明显的问题怎么能这么久得不到解决。
The railroad, the city, and the state have all taken actions to reduce incidents involving the bridge over the years, but with limited success. The railroad installed a crash beam to keep trucks from hitting the bridge itself, and this protected the infrastructure and any freight and passengers that might be traveling overhead, but it didn't do a lot for the trucks down below.
多年来，铁路公司、市政府和州政府都采取了行动来减少涉及这座桥的事故，但收效甚微。铁路公司安装了一根防撞梁，以防止卡车撞击桥梁本身，这保护了基础设施以及可能在上方通行的货物和乘客，但对下方的卡车并没有太大帮助。
Understandably, the rail company's concern is not with the trucks on the road, but the trains on the rails. For its part, the city of Durham installed a supplemental array of warning mechanisms, introducing three low-clearance signs posted at each of three intersections in advance of the bridge. A pair of smaller roadside signs with a stated height limit of 11 feet 8 inches were also put up, which shaped a few inches
可以理解的是，铁路公司的关注点不在路上的卡车，而在铁轨上的列车。作为回应，达勒姆市安装了一套补充警告机制，在桥梁前方的三个路口各设置了三个限高标志。还设立了一对较小的路边标志，标称限高为11英尺8英寸，这比实际极限减少了几英寸
off the actual limit to introduce another safety buffer. At one point, the state of North Carolina also installed an over-height while flashing sign with blinking orange lights directly in front of the bridge. Trucks, however, continued to crash into the beam. So the sign was removed in 2016 and replaced with a higher tech, over-height-must-turn variant coupled with an LED display, all linked with sensors to detect approaching oversized vehicles. The system was integrated with a new traffic light so that when the sensors were tripped, the stoplight would turn red.
以引入另一个安全缓冲。有一段时间，北卡罗来纳州还在桥梁正前方安装了一个带有闪烁橙色灯光的超高闪烁标志。然而，卡车仍然不断撞击防撞梁。因此，该标志于2016年被移除，取而代之的是技术更高、带有LED显示屏的“超高必须转弯”变体，所有这些都与检测接近超大车辆的传感器相连。该系统与新的交通灯集成在一起，当传感器被触发时，红绿灯就会变红。
The idea was to give the truck drivers more time to notice the warning sign before plowing ahead. Despite this more sophisticated intervention, however, the bridge continued to claim and maim trucks. Since no amount of warnings seemed sufficient, other solutions were considered over the years like raising the bridge, lowering the street, or redirecting truck traffic entirely. The railroad long argued that raising the bridge would require significant regrading on both sides, potentially costing millions of dollars. Lowering the street was also deemed impractical because a sewer main runs directly below it.
这个想法是给卡车司机更多的时间在猛冲过去之前注意到警告标志。然而，尽管采取了这种更复杂的干预措施，这座桥仍然不断“收割”和撞击卡车。由于任何数量的警告似乎都不够，多年来人们考虑了其他解决方案，例如抬高桥梁、降低街道或完全重定向卡车交通。铁路公司长期以来一直认为，抬高桥梁需要在两侧进行大量的路基平整，可能会耗资数百万美元。降低街道也被认为是不切实际的，因为有一条污水主管道直接从其下方穿过。
Installing a low clearance bar in advance of the bridge or otherwise redirecting over-height traffic away from the area entirely would be challenging too. Delivery trucks need to be able to drive right up to the bridge, then turn in order to access a set of restaurants nearby. Rerouting them just isn't feasible. Finally, after years of delays and buck passing, in October of 2019, a work crew converged
在桥前安装低净空栏杆或将超高车辆完全引开该区域也是具有挑战性的。送货卡车需要能够直接开到桥前，然后转弯才能到达附近的一组餐厅。重新规划路线根本不可行。最后，经过多年的拖延和推卸责任，在2019年10月，一个施工队聚集
on the site to do the improbable and raise the bridge. What was once the 11'8 bridge is now more or less a 12'4 bridge, according to the new road flanking height limit signs, though according to Yergin-Hens measurements, the actual clearance is around 12 feet 8 inches. For the not so low cost of half a million dollars, the North Carolina Railroad Company jacked up their tracks as much as they could without impacting nearby crossings on either side of the can opener. Of course, this height still won't accommodate every truck. The state allows vehicles up to 13 feet 6 inches.
在现场做了不可思议的事情，把桥抬高了。根据新的道路侧面限高标志，曾经的11英尺8英寸的桥现在或多或少是一座12英尺4英寸的桥，不过根据耶尔金-亨斯（Yergin-Hens）的测量，实际净空约为12英尺8英寸。北卡罗来纳铁路公司花费了并非不低的的五十万美元，在不影响开罐器两侧附近交叉口的情况下，尽可能地把他们的轨道顶高了。当然，这个高度仍然无法容纳每一辆卡车。该州允许高达13英尺6英寸的车辆通行。
Sure enough, a metal chunk was clipped off the top of a truck in a video posted by Hinn just a few weeks after this fix was enabled. For decades, the Canopana Bridge has represented a perfect storm of financial limitations, physical challenges, and political bureaucracy, all conspiring against a complete and permanent design solution. Even now that the bridge has been raised, it may still prove to be a flawed piece of infrastructure and a persistent nuisance. All cities have things like this, ill-fitting byproducts of conflicting priorities that
果不其然，在这项修复工程启用几周后，欣（Hinn）发布的一段视频中，一辆卡车的顶部就被削掉了一大块金属。几十年来，“开罐器桥”一直是资金限制、物理挑战和政治官僚主义完美风暴的代表，所有这些都阻碍了彻底且永久的设计方案。即使现在桥已经抬高，它可能仍然是一个有缺陷的基础设施和一个挥之不去的麻烦。所有城市都有这样的东西，相互冲突的优先事项产生的不合拍的副产品
trip up citizens or scrape their vehicles. But few are as large, troublesome, or as widely shared on the internet as the Canopana Bridge. I was shocked to be out in the world to see a similar story play out when we were being driven around Athens, but the driver who was taking us around said, oh yeah, he sees it all the time. So we're back at the Arch in downtown Athens and the last thing we have to do is we have to walk about a block that way to Walk Street Records and we have to tell the clerk some of the stuff we like and then we just have to buy whatever record they pick out for us
让市民绊倒或刮伤他们的车辆。但很少有像“开罐器桥”那样规模庞大、令人头疼或在互联网上被广为传播的。我很震惊地发现，当我们在雅典四处游览时，类似的剧情也在世界上演，但带我们四处参观的司机说，哦，是的，他经常看到这种情况。所以我们回到了雅典市中心的拱门，我们要做的最后一件事就是步行大约一个街区到Walk Street Records，我们必须告诉店员我们喜欢的一些东西，然后我们只需买下他们为我们挑选的任何唱片
because they know what they're doing. Great, let's do it. Awesome. Okay, that's it from Athens, Georgia. Over and out. Thanks for joining us for this special Athens, Georgia edition of 99% Invisible brought to you by the Lexus GX and SiriusXM. Thanks to Eric Kavanaugh, Erin Murray, and Joy Uson for being my special guests. The new Lexus GX showcases how aesthetic appeal complements utility,
因为他们知道自己在做什么。太好了，我们开始吧。太棒了。好了，来自佐治亚州雅典的节目就到这里。通话完毕。感谢您收听由雷克萨斯GX和SiriusXM为您带来的99%隐形（99% Invisible）佐治亚州雅典特别版。感谢埃里克·卡纳瓦尔（Eric Kavanaugh）、埃琳·穆雷（Erin Murray）和乔伊·乌森（Joy Uson）作为我的特邀嘉宾。全新雷克萨斯GX展示了美学吸引力如何与实用性相辅相成，
proving luxury and capability can coexist. And when you throw SiriusXM on there, you have everything you need to be out in the furthest reaches while still being connected to a passionate community of sports fans, music-loving DJs, world-class talkers, comedians, and thinkers. To learn more about the GX and SiriusXM and Lexus vehicles, visit Lexus.com. The all-new Lexus GX. Live up to it. I also encourage you to go to this episode's page on 99pi.org, where you can look at me posing with a very fancy car, and you can watch me
证明了豪华与性能可以共存。当您加入SiriusXM时，您就拥有了身处最偏远地区所需的一切，同时仍与充满激情的体育迷、音乐爱好者DJ、世界一流的谈话节目主持人、喜剧演员和思想家社区保持联系。要了解有关GX、SiriusXM和雷克萨斯车辆的更多信息，请访问Lexus.com。全新雷克萨斯GX。不负所期。我也鼓励您访问99pi.org上本期节目的页面，在那里您可以看着我与一辆非常豪华的汽车合影，您还可以看着我
driving down the highway with it, and you can stream your first three months free of SiriusXM, where you can listen on the SiriusXM app online or on other compatible devices. You'll get more than 425 channels including ad-free music, sports, comedy, news, and more. You can listen anywhere on the all-new SiriusXM app. Go to 99pi.org to subscribe to SiriusXM. 99% of IZBELT was reported this week by Me, Roman Mars, and Kurt Kohlstedt and edited by me, Roman Mars, with production help from IZBELT Angel and Sarah Baik. Mix and sound design by Dara Hirsch.
开着它在高速公路上行驶，并且您可以免费试用前三个月的SiriusXM，您可以在线或在其他兼容设备上的SiriusXM应用程序上收听。您将获得425个以上的频道，包括无广告的音乐、体育、喜剧、新闻等。您可以在全新SiriusXM应用程序上的任何地方收听。前往99pi.org订阅SiriusXM。本周的99%隐形节目由我、罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）和库尔特·科尔施泰特（Kurt Kohlstedt）联合报道，由我、罗曼·马尔斯编辑，并得到了安杰尔（Angel）和萨拉·拜克（Sarah Baik）的制作帮助。混音和声音设计由达拉·赫施（Dara Hirsch）完成。
Music by Swan Real. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Delaney Hall is our senior editor, the rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Vivian Ley, Oshima Dawn, Christopher Johnson, Martín González, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriela Gladney, Nina Potuck, Kelly Prime, and Jacob Maldonado Medina.
音乐由Swan Real创作。凯茜·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人，德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的资深编辑，团队其他成员包括克里斯·伯鲁比（Chris Berube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、维维安·莱（Vivian Ley）、大岛晨（Oshima Dawn）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martín González）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriela Gladney）、尼娜·波图克（Nina Potuck）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）和雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado Medina）。
The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. Our headquarters online is 99pi.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99%隐形标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，总部现在位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的上城区潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。我们的在线总部是99pi.org。您该剧集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。